あのー
透明な飲み物
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
俺は本当に疑問を抱いている
今の　飲料水業界に
ホントに最近
透明な飲み物が
バンッ（テーブルを叩く音）
ビックリするくらい透明な飲み物ありますよ
なに　透明なコーラ
透明なヨーグルトの飲み物
透明なヨーグルトの飲み物のブドウバージョン
透明なイチゴドリンク
透明なカルピス
透明な爽健美茶
透明なレモンティー
透明なピーチ！！
本当にビックリするくらい
透明な飲み物ブームが今来てまして
コーラまで透明になっちゃう
これはどうしたことかと
僕は疑問を持っております
なんでなんですかね
やっぱ透明のほうがなんか飲んだ感がないから
痩せる気がするんですかね
パッと見僕が
今売ってる目に入った
え？　これ透明じゃないっしょ
って思った飲み物一覧でございます
透明なコーラってもうすごいですよ
色あってこそのコーラみたいなところあるんで
ホントビックリしました
いただきます
うーんなんか
でも多分コーラの味なんだと思います
ヨーグリーナ
ブルーベリーヨーグリーナ
おーわーぁ…
いろはすイチゴ
どうなんだろこれどうなってんだろ
おぁ予想以上にイチゴ！
透明なカルピスとかマジお前さそれヤバいぜ
おわぁ透き通ってんなぁ
これさぁもうすごいのよ
爽健…
お茶じゃないんだ！？
おぅあ…
爽健美茶を極力薄めた感じかな
透明なレモンティー
あぁうん
普通のレモンティー
透明なピーチティー
うーん美味しい
いろはすの白桃も結構濃かった気がします
ウィルキンソン炭酸にオレンジ味が出ていたとは
これも透明ブームのせいなのだろうか
おぁー結構味きいてんねぇ
パンッ（頬を打つ音）
天然水オレンジ
オレンジジュースなんだろうなぁ結局
クッソ
なんでおめぇら透明なんだよ！
ただ一つ言えることは
ここで私またあることに気付いてしまった
なぜ飲み物の会社は
透明な飲料水を次から次へと作ってしまうのだろうか
その理由はただ一つ
透明な飲み物の美味しさの限界に
みんな挑んでいるのです
知らないけど
ってことはですよ
君たちみんな透明なのに
味を求めてるんだったら
私はそう思ってしまいました
つまりあれだ
一言で言うと
見てください
こいつら
透明なくせして
お前たちはなんだ
赤 金 紫 黄緑 青 緑 黒兄弟 黄緑 白 オレンジ
戦隊モノです
つまり
燃え盛ってますよ
こんな個性あるやつらが
力を合わせたら
どうなるのか！
見てみたいと思います
これはかなり極論を言わせていただきますと
理にかなった動画だと思います
透明な飲み物の限界
そこに到達するためには
全ての味のある飲み物の力を
合体させなければいけない
そうだろ！？（飲み物への問いかけ）
なんか言ってくれよ
おそらく２年後には
世の中の全ての飲み物の色が無くなります
そして５年後
人間は色を失い
１０年後
この世は全て透明になってしまうでしょう
この実験に成功して
俺は未来を変えるしかない
そして俺は
神になる！
やります
結局透明だから
多分動画的には何にも面白くないんだろうね
できた
ホントキャップがレンジャーもんなんだよなぁ
ちょっと混ぜていきます
~♪（バーテンダーなBGM）
待ってすっげー泡立ってんだけど
それもなんか
洗剤レベルで泡立ってんだけど
果たして
現在の飲み物テクノロジーの頂点に君臨する
透明な飲み物
彼らの味が交わった時
どのような味になるのでしょうか
飲んでみます！
うわっ！ビックリした！
なんで爆発した！？
なんか言ってくれ
あっなんかお風呂場の匂いがします
いいボディーソープを使った後の
お風呂場の匂いがします
うん
今日もバスロマン
待って
なんだなんだ？
なんだこれ？
あっ
メントスの破片を
水に溶かした味がします
お前らどこに向かってるんだよ